hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots baby merch please set up our
guests L while I pull them up here
ladies and gentlemen joining us is uh uh
uh highly avowed friend of the show uh
good pal great drinking buddy yes and
avowed domestic terrorist Owen Shroyer
joining us from the War Room what up
buddy what up ow well let's just let's
just be perfectly clear here I am uh I
am totally sober nowadays the uh the US
government has me under very strict
watch so unfortunately I might not be
the best drinking buddy anymore I can't
really travel I can't really do anything
in fact if one of you two happens to be
a felon I actually have to cancel this
interview right now I don't think I'm a
felon yet not yet oh there goes mer okay
it's just me and you I
guess nah none of the felonies ever
stuck knock on wood good most other
stuff sticks to you but that's good that
not everything else especially in this
humidity wait so you still have like
Community Control [__] that they're
doing still yeah I got honestly man it's
crazy uh I I my my my my probation is
essentially the probation that violent
criminals get and people that launder
like millions of dollars receive um so
how long is it it's crazy it's for a
year it's for a year travel travel
restrictions Communications restrictions
I get uh I get drug tested regularly
randomly um all kinds of crazy crap yeah
can't talk to felons can't talk to any
prisoners that is absolutely insane so
it's it's not even so of course you know
putting putting you in [__] prison
was was horn obviously but that's the
other part and then they they you're
still a [__] slave to the government
for another year MH that is that is that
is just so so [__] gross and and and
P&P like probation parole [__] it's it's
having done probation before and having
known a lot of people that have done
probation before I've even had friends
that said look if you get uh a judge
that says you're going to do 30 to 60
days in jail or you're going to get a
year probation if it's a choice in some
cases people I know people that go I'll
just take the time because probation is
set up for you to fail it that's all
they want it's not set up to reform
anybody or to hey we're just you know
keep it clean for a year they are like
oh they are hoping you [__] it up like
that's all they want a probation officer
is not trying to steer you clear they
they want you to [__] it
up well and I'll just say too just In
fairness because I've had I've been on
probation since
2019 uh the political person acution of
of me really has been going on for
multiple years uh but but In fairness
there are some good probation officers
not every probation officer wants to see
you fail not every probation officer
wants to [__] you over like that um
there are certainly some that do I think
it probably depends on um let's say
their client if you will like man most
of the probation officers I've dealt
with they look at my case and they just
they kind of like scratch my they
scratch their head and they're like what
are you even doing here why why are you
even here and and the thing is it's like
you know they don't they don't really
understand they probably don't follow
politics like we follow politics um in
my most recent probation meeting there
was some stuff that got brought up and
um there was a question CU these things
are really invasive actually people
might be surprised to find out how
invasive some of these probation
meetings are it's just that's just the
uh the routine if you will and there was
a questionnaire you got to fill out this
questionnaire and there was this
questionaire that was like do you feel
that you have been unfairly uh
prosecuted by the system or the system
is out to get you and I'm just reading
this in my head and I kind of burst out
into laughter and the probation officer
sitting there in the room with me and he
must think I'm insane he goes he goes
what's so funny and uh I I read the
question back to him and I was like well
the question asked if I think I've been
uh targeted by the system and uh I don't
think he fully got it and then there was
something else that came up that he
asked me and I was like I was like you
haven't really done much investigating
into my case have you and uh he he ENT
he essentially said well I mean I know
it's uh kind of a high-profile case but
I could tell he he really doesn't
understand the nature the full nature of
it and by the way I I think I'm lucky I
think the probation officer I have right
now is a good person and I don't think
he's looking to uh I don't think he's
looking to [__] me over I think he's
he's hoping I stay out of trouble for
probably his own sake too he doesn't
like it when people probably looks bad
on him when people um fail their
probation but he looks at mine and he's
just stunned it's I have a less than
trespassing misdemeanor I have a
entering restricted government grounds
misdemeanor and I am being treated like
a violent criminal I'm being treated
like somebody who's spent years in
prison I'm being treated like somebody
that's laundered millions of dollars
that that's the
probationary uh cautions that the
government has me under right now the US
government has my passport the US
government has my driver's license I
mean it's just it's insane and the stuff
that I've done of course there are
hundreds if not thousands of liberal
Democrats that have done much worse and
don't receive a minute of jail time or
probation and you know I first off that
it's it is you could just just easily go
look online and see people that have
done criminal acts violent criminal acts
that have not been treated that way and
of course it's political persecution and
you know I I listened uh I I man I I
heard a lot of your interviews and I
think some of the stuff that I I think
is is really shocking is people don't
really understand because there was a
lot of fake news for lack of a better
term that was coming up when the left
when when you had gone in and you know
there were just people just making up
stories and this and that but that you
would you did was a misdemeanor and they
were treating you like they treat a
violent felon like he was [__] Steve
BMI and Conair right exactly the [__]
Hannibal Lector mask yeah exactly and
and and it it it really it really blows
it really blows my mind how easy it is
and if it wasn't honestly for Elon
taking over taking over Twitter people
wouldn't even know the truth and the
media manipulated to to really try to
make you look like some sort of violent
insurrectionist but when you hear what
really happened and and they had no
basis to do this people need to be
worried because there's a lot of people
that might not like you might not like
infow Wars might not like Alex might
like anybody but like if they could do
it to you they could do it to anybody to
anybody when you are pushing against
them when they don't like what you're
saying they will un they will try to
unperson you well and you hear this a
lot to oh well just don't do anything
wrong just stay out of trouble you know
just stay in your lane all this stuff
and I and I just sit there and I look at
people that say that and and maybe I
have been that person at some time in
the past but I just look at people and I
say that and I'm just like you have no
clue you just that is that is one of the
most ignorant statements or assumptions
that you can make is that oh just you
know just keep your nose clean just stay
in your lane just don't do anything
wrong and and you'll be fine uh yeah
tell that to uh many of the people that
are wrongfully incarcerated in this
country you know that that was a lesson
that I learned being in the bureau of
prison system is how many people don't
belong in there you'd actually be
stunned uh to find out how many
nonviolent offenders and how many people
are sitting in prison right now simply
because the government has these new
arms that they can use to force you to
take a plea agreement and some of these
things are going to be challenged in
court like relevant conduct there's this
other thing called ghost dope or
basically they can they they don't even
have to catch you with any drugs but if
they get somebody saying that he saw you
with drugs or he knows you're affiliated
with drugs and they just arrest you on
hearsay uh so there's a lot of stuff
that I learned a lot of legal Concepts
that get used against the people because
all that happens in the system is and
I've said this at nauseum but I'm never
going to stop saying it until it's not
true anymore there is Justice never
enters the equation when it comes to the
justice department never enters it and
until you're in that courtroom and
you've got the judge here and you've got
the prosecutors and US attorneys here
and then you're over here and you
actually witness it for yourself and you
have that feeling of loneliness and you
have that feeling of isolation and you
have that feeling of hopelessness
knowing that wow I never had a chance
here I never had a chance at Justice in
this courtroom the whole thing was
weighed against me the whole thing was
rigged against me uh that that feeling
of emptiness until you felt it you can't
even comprehend it the US attorneys and
the prosecutors have one thing in mind
and that's conviction
and then the judge's motivation is
incarceration Justice never enters the
equation here never and until you've
actually been on the receiving end of
that it's something that's hard to even
conceive or understand but as somebody
that's been there I'm telling you it's
very very real and it's much worse it's
much worse than we realize I yeah I look
I got to say just word of advice though
next time you're uh with your probation
officer and you laugh and he goes what
are you laughing at just say I was
thinking of something from
yesterday start reading his own
questions back to him it's probably he
might probably won't like you also we
have to ask the fans have been really
really just RAR in don't know which
which gang did you join yeah did what
was it AB was it the Nortenos like what
do we you're not an MS13 guy I don't
think no no you know I got to say there
were a lot of beautiful offers um
process they're all trying to draft Owen
yeah the courting process was beautiful
really uh it was
you know it was hard it was hard to uh
it was a hard thing uh no actually the
so the prison I went to was one of the
least political prisons uh in the Bop
the the the strange thing about that is
because it's actually one of the few
prisons where chomos can walk the yard
that's child molesters really yeah
because most prisons you go to at least
federal prisons I mean most gangs they
beat up child molesters like it's all
it's part of kind of all of their
cultures to beat up child molesters and
the funny thing is the prison culture
the inmates uh probably deal with child
molesters better than the Department of
Justice does but the thing about the
prison I was at is that it's a lot of
guys that are trying to get out it's a
lot of guys that have worked their way
down from higher security prisons it's a
lot of guys that are trying to get out
on good time there there was some some
uh gang affiliations there I can tell
you some stories but it's not it's it's
one of the least political prisons out
there and so really the gang involvement
or the gang activity there wasn't as uh
heavy-handed or involved in the process
as it might have been other places but I
I will tell you um you know you do kind
of fall into some categories and some
ranks you do meet some people um and I I
would say uh the Nanos are actually some
of the nicest people uh they are very
nice people in there um I don't think I
can qualify because uh I don't have the
uh right uh let's say racial makeup but
uh they were they were some very nice
people in there um and then really
though I fell into What's called the
Texas Independence because I'm
unaffiliated and I'm from Texas and I'm
white so I kind of just organically fall
into what is called the Texas
Independence it's like in Oz he he was
the one that would hang out with like uh
uh what's his face uh the the the main
guy and like the wheelchair guy they
just had that group that wasn't a gang
and us they play chess and [__] but I
did get along with everybody then yeah
so so I heard you I believe it was in
the Tucker interview you brought
something up great that was a great
interview by the way but but you did
bring something up that I I thought was
was I I think a lot more people on the
right need to hear this and you you you
touched on a little bit but there's
there there is a there is a problem with
the people that we are incarcerating
that you were saying a lot of these
people shouldn't be in jail and it feels
like everything is reversed like the did
did you see a lot of people there did
you think would just run up the
river I I would say and my experience is
in one prison and so I don't I I don't
want to of course I don't want to jump
to any broader conclusions but from my
experience I mean I would say the
majority of people that were in that
prison do not belong there Point Blank
do not belong there I mean you got to
understand that I made this comparison
somewhere else too if there's a VIN
diagram it's to to find the center point
if we're doing a Camala Harris
exhibition here you
have basically a daycare and then an old
folks home and then a concentration camp
and the prison system is the VIN diagram
that has all the all the common things
that all three of those have in common
most of the time inside of this system
it's just old guys sitting around
watching TV that's it they're not a
threat to anybody they never were a
threat to anybody they're never going to
be a threat to anybody that's like most
of the activity that goes on there as
far as I could tell most the vast
majority of people that were inside the
prison with me because you got to
understand this word travels faster than
anything else in prison most things in
prison time and process moves extremely
slow but word spreads fast not just
between inmates but between the guards
and everything too so who I was and what
I do and everything that spread
relatively quickly even when I was
sitting in solitary so you can imagine
people find out you have a talk show
that's pretty famous everybody wants you
to tell their story everybody wants to
tell me their story and they want me to
take their story out into the real world
so I I I happen to learn a lot through
that process and most the vast majority
of people that were in there are
nonviolent criminals nonviolent
criminals uh a lot of people that maybe
got caught dealing some drugs some
people that were laundering money so
they didn't have to pay their taxes uh
and then there were a lot of people that
were were trying to fight against the
corrupt medical insurance Medicare and
Medicaid institutions uh that get locked
up because you can find anybody I mean
there's I I forget the name of the book
but you you commit like 17 felonies a
day or whatever so I mean if you work in
the Medicare field and you go up against
the medical establishment they find they
easily find ways to charge you and put
you in jail uh so I learned about that I
mean there's all kinds of crazy stuff I
learned about in there I'm I'm writing a
book about it as well I'm hoping to have
that published um sometime I mean
realistically probably in the spring or
summer of next year it's quite a project
uh on top of everything else I'm doing
but yeah most people don't believe in
there so there was a hearing I'm sure
you heard Matt Gates brought my name up
during the Bop hearing with Colette
Peters and they're demanding two billion
more dollars they're saying we're short
we need two billion more dollars well
most of the stuff she said she said is
right the the the the physical
infrastructure of the prisons is a
disaster I mean I'm showering in black
mold showers I mean you can imagine the
actual infrastructure as you're in there
I mean you're sleeping on a a mattress
pad that's like an inch inch and a half
thick I can go on and on with that I
mean rusted out lockers to put your
stuff in I thought actually I was going
to get sick because I there was like a
jagged edge of this Locker that I cut
myself on um uh luckily it wasn't
infected and I've I've had medical tests
done on me since I've gotten out to make
sure I'm okay uh for a bunch of
different reasons but yeah I'm all I'm
all good on that and then she talks
about how the staff is unmotivated and
incompetent and all this stuff oh yeah
uh believe me that's true uh some of the
laziest people I've ever met worked at
this prison I mean stunning levels of
laziness and I don't want to make the
worst I don't want to make a blanket
statement because there were a lot of
good people there too a lot of good PE
lot of good people on both sides people
um but some of the most lazy incompetent
people I've ever seen in my life worked
at that prison so she's right she
probably does need that but they don't
need two billion more dollars of our
money what they need to do is find the
equation of what how many prisoners
equate to $2 billion a year and just
release them tomorrow you need two
billion dollar release $2 billion do of
prisoners tomorrow and that will solve
your problem and that'll be better for
everybody I mean you have you have
fathers that are just sitting in those
prison right now multiple kids Sons just
sitting in those prisons right now that
nonviolent criminals and society would
be much more benefited if they were at
home with their families even if you
have on house arrest at home with their
families instead of rotting away in
prisons I mean so many examples of that
it would blow the average person's mind
yeah but prison's big business man you
you know how the feds work if you ow if
you run a department and you don't spend
all the money then they don't give you
as much money next year so you always
got to have new money so there's money
and locking people up it sucks that's
just the truth and feeding them and clo
them and the hygiene products and the
products that come into the commissary
oh yeah it's a business and speaking of
you know feeding them and all that I
wanted to get into that how did you H
how did they how how did how did you end
up in solitary what happened
there I was a speech prisoner and then I
was a speech prisoner inside of the
prison so basically as you know my
speech is what landed me in the federal
prison
now I don't know if this is policy
everywhere or if it it was just this
prison I'm pretty sure what they did is
illegal but that's a whole another story
as soon as you get in they put you in
quarantine for covid now I didn't have
covid I wasn't sick and they put me in
quarantine they're still doing that
they're still doing Co still doing still
doing it I don't even think it's legal
but they're still doing it now the way
the quarantine works is it's supposed to
be five days but because my fifth day
landed on a Saturday
I didn't get out till Monday so I spent
my first seven days in quarantine so I
get out sometime I believe it was Monday
afternoon and the first thing I do is I
I go and I make a phone call to let
people know that I'm out of solitary and
that I got your mail and your books and
thank you very much you know God bless
very vanilla milk toast message just
just heartfelt thanking people maybe two
minutes well it gets put up and goes
viral on the internet now I'm sure as
you have seen and many of your audience
have seen people call into talk shows
and do podcasts and all kinds of stuff
from prison all the time yeah tiger
tiger tiger King famously does there's
one you can go on the internet right now
and find all kinds of videos and stuff
coming out from inside prisons yeah
happens all the time rappers record
entire albums over the phone it's
unbelievable yeah well that phone call
gives gets me what's called a shot which
is basic basically a disciplinary action
inside the prison which winds me up in
the special housing unit which is which
is basically like it's the prison inside
of the prison shank someone if you shank
someone or rape somebody or smuggle
Contraband in they send you to the shoe
well that phone call had me sent to the
shoe so I was I was a speech prisoner
inside the prison for my speech in so I
was like a speech prisoner squar if you
can believe that and I was supposed to
spend my nearly my entire sentence
inside the shoe uh if it wasn't for some
good guys let's say that work inside the
Bop I got released early but I was told
off record and these conversations are
off record and I got to be careful what
I say but I'll just give you the gist of
it the whole treatment of me in that
facility was being called from the
higher ups higher ups the highest on the
food chain at the at the Department of
Justice and they and they basically
pulled me aside and they said look Owen
your beef isn't with us we like you we
like your content sadly I heard it too
many times but we're just doing our job
but they wanted to make sure hey they
say oh your beef is not with us we don't
think you belong here I mean I had I had
the the the highest level official that
you can get inside these prisons who's
worked in prisons for decades have a
meeting with me and he said Owen I have
never seen anybody railroaded by the
justice system like you I've never seen
anybody with a misdemeanor in a federal
prison ever in my life nobody's heard of
that by the way as far as we can tell
I'm still the only person with a
misdemeanor to be in a federal prison
so I mean I became a speech I was a
speech prisoner and then I was put
inside the prison the prison inside the
prison for my speech and I was told this
this came from the higher up so it was
that it was that phone call many of your
audience or or you guys may have heard
it but it was very vanilla just thanking
people for the mail and the books and
that was it and uh they locked me up for
that and they were G to keep me inside
the shoe for that for my virtually my
entire sentence but I got released early
thank God Jesus that that is brutal man
isolation is like the most brutal thing
they can do yeah how was it I mean that
that's got to be rough I mean you lost
weight yeah you look at you lost weight
lost a lot of weight yeah I lost 15
pounds while I was in there wow that
that was my prediction too remember that
I said man watch he's just going to come
out cutting weight like [__] and then
we saw you at the border the yesterday
I'm like damn look homeboy did lose some
weight
so I lost 15 pounds in there and uh I've
probably gained most of it back by now I
haven't I haven't weighed myself in a in
a couple days but I probably have gained
most of it back by now I've been eating
good what was the first meal was the
first meal what was your first meal when
you got out well H this is this is kind
of a two-part answer because when I got
when I got picked up by uh by my buddies
there's a whole another story that'll
blow your mind about the drop off pickup
if you want yeah dude we we got let me
let me answer your question first um it
was not my decision but my ride home was
hungry and so they wanted to stop it
Raising Canes okay all right all right
not that and so I wasn't going to eat it
because I wasn't hungry you got to
understand when you're in jail your
appetite and everything changes went
into keto yeah basically yeah your body
just went into starvation mode yeah
something yeah oh yeah no you you get
used to starving that's pretty much you
you're starving all the time and you're
sleep deprived all the time but I wasn't
hungry I wasn't going to eat I was like
well whatever I'll I'll I'll eat some
fried chicken and so uh I had some fried
chicken from canes and really it just
did not sit well it just didn't it just
wasn't really good for me and that was
early in the morning and so that I
wouldn't even really count that I didn't
eat the rest of the day and then that
night I went to a one of my favorite
steakhous now we talking just had the
full spread I mean I had the full spread
crab cakes Lobster bis steak all grotten
potatoes cream spinach I mean I was
going to be very let down if you didn't
go get a steak where you live and like
what you guys have around there well
yeah of course I a Ste but you
understand I eat like two three steaks a
day like that's my that's just my normal
diet is I just am eating steak and eggs
all day long I was wrong my guess my
guess was going to be McDonald's my
statistically because I've been to jail
before statistically speaking it's
almost always McDonald's like people
because there's a McDonald's everywhere
that's true and it's because it's
garbage but man when you've been in
there just eating like moly bread and
[__] you're like get me to a McDonald
All I want right now is like some
nuggets or Big Mac and french fries and
a coke yeah you said you said they
didn't even let you access your
Commissary for like most of the time
right yeah I think it was 35 days until
I got commissary excess oh wow and for
people that don't understand what that
means that virtually means that you
don't get any food other than what the
prisons provide you don't get any
hygiene products you don't get any of
your own clothes so I'm running around
in sweat stained boxers and t-shirts and
all kinds of crap uh yeah it was about I
think it was 35 days till I got access
to commentary
but man I'm tell you this is all the
details of this going to come out in my
book because it's honestly unbelievable
like this all this stuff blows your mind
so this is a whole another story that
I'll tell you sure the day I got out of
solitary it was Monday afternoon the
next day was commissary day so we go to
the commissary and again that's where
you get most people get junk food there
but I don't really like potato chips
whatever I don't I don't eat junk food
so I got like grains and peanut butter
and and nuts and stuff like that
I tried to I was as healthy as I could
get basically and then some clothes so I
could have my own clothes and some shoes
so you can have your own shoes and and
not the the the ratty rubber prison
shoes that they give you okay so we go
to commissary we get back and there's
lockdowns and counts uh uh at least two
a day so we're so we're in a lockdown
and I put all my commissary stuff in my
rusted Locker well I get pulled out of
my cell and this is when they send me to
the shoe so all my commissary about 200
letters that I'd received in the first
week and probably about 50 to 100 books
that I've received in the first week is
all there in my locker well when they
transfer you from your unit to the shoe
they take all of your property and
they're supposed to put it in bags check
it into the shoe you're supposed to
review it make sure it's all there and
there's the whole
process they lost or stole all of my
property all of it there's no way they
lost yeah that's Pro that's stolen they
yeah I mean I know you have to say they
lost or I'll say it they stole your [__]
bro I'll say that yeah that's what it
seems like and and and so what happened
so nothing happened I'm actually now I'm
in a legal process with the Bop oh my
God uh to try to and but here's the
problem the commissary value was like
$360 of food and clothes right okay 360
bucks whatever buys me a nice steak
dinner that the property fine it's
replaceable it was the 200 letters some
of which I hadn't even opened yet that's
value uh uh that's value can't even be
measured of course uh the first the
first seven days of my book entry so
we're talking like 25 30 pages of
writing that I had done completely gone
we're talking about books that people
had gifted me some of which were
leatherbound and some of which were
extremely rare and I happen to know
they're very expensive because I've
looked into buying a few them myself and
it just so happened some of them gifted
them to me so I mean it was easily
probably $15 to $2,500 worth of property
but again the pricelessness of my
writing and letters from friends and
family and loved ones is it can't be
replaced so so that's just magically
gone I mean somehow inside the prison
system all of it's gone all my
commissary is gone and so that's why I
was without Commissary for the first uh
35 days because then when I got released
from the shoe I think it was like
another week before we even got got to
go to commissary so I've got more
details uh as far as that process uh
that that I'm writing inside my book but
listen to this drop off story this is
like I mean I'm telling you guys the
incompetence inside of the system the
laziness and
incompetence uh inside of this system it
it's so mindblowing that you're just in
awe I mean your jaw just hits the floor
to the people that have been there long
enough there're they're so used to it
but so they give you your release date
and
normally I nobody can answer why they
wouldn't let me have a personal vehicle
the usually the only reasons why they
won't let you have a personal vehicle is
if you're indignant you have no friends
nobody cares about you no family and so
you just can't even get yourself a ride
or if you're some sort of a high class
felon that engaged in like major drug
dealing or money laundering and they're
afraid that you're going to link up with
one of your criminal buddies as soon as
you get out right usually those are are
the reasons why they don't allow you a
personal vehicle pickup well they never
gave me a reason why they wouldn't allow
me to have a personal vehicle pickup I
requested a personal vehicle pickup they
wouldn't do it so they arranged for me
to take a bus to Austin and and you you
can't even imagine how absurd this is in
my circumstances because I've got five
trash bags full of property books
letters I mean the amount of books I
received is just insane so they're
asking me to hop on a Greyhound bus with
these five trash bags full of books and
mail okay I have no access to a cell
phone they don't let you bring anything
in no wallet no ID I mean no nothing you
basically have the clothes on your back
and then whatever property you have and
I an exorbitant amount of property just
because of all the mail and the books I
received so they so they arranged me a
bus that goes from Lafayette Louisiana
to Houston Texas to San Antonio Texas to
Austin Texas like 12-h hour bus ride or
something well
I'm able to arrange through a liaison a
pickup and I and I give uh individual in
the prison my bus ticket information and
I say um can you call this individual
for me give him this information tell
him this is where I'm going to be this
is when I'm going to be there and and
then he can pick me up okay so that gets
done so I've got I've got my uh
arrangement for a ride to pick me up
from the bus stop at Lafayette Louisiana
because they won't let anybody pick me
up from the prison
so get this this is I get released at
midnight technically so so so early
Friday morning let's say just just
midnight Thursday night I get released a
Bureau of Prisons driver takes me to the
Lafayette Louisiana bus stop where I am
supposed to catch a bus and but where
I'm also supposed to meet my ride they
dropped me off at the wrong bus stop
Jesus Christ I'm stuck at the wrong bus
stop at 2:00 a.m. in the morning it's
30° out all I have is a is a shirt I
bought in prison and some sweatpants
five trash bags full of property no cell
phone no ID no wallet no access to
anything I'm sitting at a random bus
stop in a city I've never been in before
freezing for hours because they dropped
me off at the wrong bus stop now
thankfully the individuals that I had
arranged to pick me up were uh you know
competent enough to realize after 30
minutes to an hour passed and I wasn't
there they said hey something's wrong
here let's see if there's any other bus
stops in the area so they just get on a
Maps app plug in bus stops and they're
able to find a uh another bus stop and
they drive to it I'm standing outside um
I'm pacing around reading a book just
trying to stay warm hope hoping they're
going to show up eventually cuz at that
time I didn't even know I was at the
wrong bus stop I don't know what the
hell's going on and how yeah how would
how would you know that there would be
no way for you to know that that yeah so
you were just luck I mean that's pretty
smart of them though to think about you
know looking the other bus stop but I
mean so they messed that up and and like
you said I would would do you chalk that
up to just laziness by by by by the
staff or because I mean I don't I mean
if I'm me I'm just telling you me like I
would at some point wouldn't you be
start taking this [__] [__] personal
like I would like this is this is
personal now like what you know what I
mean and I'm not talking about obviously
I think a lot of the stuff they're doing
you from high up is personal but even
the day-to-day stuff like that's just
feels cruel on purpose you know I think
that a lot of the treatment that that
happened to me was from the higher ups
but honestly when it comes to like the
situation with the bus stop I don't know
about the property but uh I mean really
man it it really is just incompetence
and laziness you guys to understand that
the way prisoners get treated and this
is part of the larger story I think that
I have to tell now the way prisoners get
treated is is inhumane they they get
treated like a number but really that
explanation doesn't even properly
summarize it they the way they get
treated is basically like nobody cares
about you nobody's ever going to care
about you I can do whatever I want to
you say whatever I want to you
disrespect you in ways that you don't
deserve and it just doesn't matter
because nobody's ever going to hear
about it and so it just doesn't matter
and so I think they can't help
themselves um I don't think that the guy
unintentionally drop or intentionally
drop me off at the wrong bus stop I I
really don't believe that maybe I'm
wrong but I don't think that's the case
I think it's just another case of they
just don't care yeah and they have no
reason to because they never get
punished when they when they act
incompetently they never get punished
for their flagrant laziness I mean
what's going to happen to the people
that Dro me off at the wrong bus stop
probably nothing no they'll get promoted
actually huh no they'll get promoted
actually it's a government bureaucratic
system ah yeah well you know good good
job good job you killed it but like you
said you know you said it earlier when
when you even go into the prose
prosecutors and the judges when your job
is performance is numbers that takes
Humanity completely out of the equation
there's no justice there's no Humanity
it's like how many prises did you
transport you did this you did that it
doesn't Fe it feels like from not just
from you but from when I've heard like
there's the the the the human connection
is lost you become kind of like cattle
you know that that's moved around and
and I think that you know we've said
that too I I think that that's a big
reason why a lot of people reoffend
that's not a nobody who gets
rehabilitated in prison do you know
anybody that's actually gone to prison
and got I have now been rehabilitated
because their programs were so good it
just get if anything it's the opposite
if anything it's the opposite I can
understand how people it's not that you
get used to the treatment it's just
that it it's so in a way it's so hard to
try to readjust to normal life and for
me I mean look I I served a short
sentence I'm not I'm not acting like I
had the toughest ride of a prison
sentence here um but I can I have enough
perspective to understand that trying to
readjust to normal life after that might
be so hard for people that they just
don't even want to and they just give up
but you know there's also another aspect
ECT of prison culture where some people
want to be there uh and this is a
totally different story um but some
people want to be in prison because they
think it brings them street cred or they
figure it's it's an easier life for them
in there than it is on the
outside um but really the prison system
there's because the theory is that
there's two theories of thought uh and
it's Rehabilitation or punishment and I
can tell you that there's no effort as
far as I can tell to rehab anybody in
there and what really needs to happen if
you believe in rehab as the theory for
imprisonment then honestly I I think the
prison system that what what needs to
happen is you really need to have the
opportunity to go in there and become
the best person you can be and obviously
there's not going to be everybody that's
interested in that and so you can
essentially through the process weed out
the ones that want to better themselves
and and put them in different situations
but the ones that do want to better
themselves and become a better person
whatever that means uh they should have
that opportunity I mean honestly like
you should you should get a taste of
even how could I say this like you
should be able to get a taste of a
lifestyle that you you've never
experienced on the outside inside the
prison like having a nice meal like
actually having a steak for dinner
having a nice gym where you can go and
and work out having people that actually
care care about you around you I feel
like that's rehab once you've kind of
seen that that potential is there for
you if you work hard and apply yourself
and then you can see how oh wow I really
do have more that I can be wow I really
do have more potential once you have
that and you get out well now all of a
sudden the world is your oyster but once
you've been beaten down and and
destroyed and punished and felt like
you're lesser of a person it it it's
such a psychological trauma that you get
out into the real world and you're just
like this is too much this is
overwhelming I'm a piece of crap I
belong back into the prison so I I can
see it's kind of like the it's kind of
like the end of The Hurt Locker right
when he goes into the grocery store and
it just freaks him out because he's not
there's so much I I can see that and you
hear a lot I I've known people that that
that would rather be in jail I mean it
be because it's that what are you going
to do when you get out and there is a
stigma too if you've ever been into like
I don't I I honestly believe that a lot
of people go in there they serve their
time but then there's a stigma that well
okay but but I served my time I did what
I needed to do when am I allowed to be a
citizen again like okay I get it you
punished me and I think that stigma
follows you forever because okay you're
rehabilitated you did your time good
luck getting a job you know well and a
lot of times the way a lot of these
probations work mine isn't uh quite as
as strict as others when it comes to
their employment but a lot of times the
employment parameters on probation are
so strict that really the only place you
can even get a job is like a minimum
wage job at a fast food restaurant or or
something like that because the
parameters are so restrictive and and
people just look at that and they're
like well basically I have the choice to
either uh you know work at McDonald's or
or work in uh you know I don't know some
job that they don't want but uh they
just figure okay well I just don't want
to be here I don't want to be on the
outside well jokes on you US Government
I've already ruined my own
life so your move I
guess be careful don't tempt them
yeah no there's one thing the government
they'll always find a new creative way
to ruin your life it can always be worse
it can always be worse so the next thing
there's plenty of federal pens in
Florida dude trust me we know I get
pulled over later and they do the old uh
you know the Walking Tall thing where
they bust my tail light out and then I'm
like wait a minute why is the FBI doing
routine traffic stops and busting my
tail light out I I will say something
that I that I saw that was was was kind
of a white pill was the outpouring of
support you got on social media was was
was was great to see like even people
that that that wouldn't necessarily
normally like you does anyone not like
you besides a few people Department of
Justice yeah I mean because I think that
no it's funny you say that because we
we've have we we have happened to hang
out a couple times and uh most people
that meet me really like me I'm actually
I'm actually a really likable guy I get
get along with everybody even some of
the leftwing um pundits that used to
write and I say used to because after
they met me they quit writing hit pieces
on me right they liked me they were like
yeah actually you you're not the person
that we thought you were you're actually
a really nice guy so I actually get
along with everybody um I got along with
pretty much everybody in prison too
that's a that's uh kind of a similar
thing I guess to the outside but
Twitter down always oh go ahead to Echo
what you're saying the outpouring of
support was overwhelming and actually I
understand why a lot of people are
blackpilled these days but the
outpouring of support was so impactful
on me personally that it reaffirmed my
faith in the American people and I'm and
I specifically say the American people
because that's who it was and I have to
give a big shout out big credit to um
the people that were working behind the
scenes on my social media account and
some of the people at Infowars for doing
such a great job and and they really did
an incredible job they went above and
beyond if it wasn't for that I I don't
know if that that support and that
influence would have been so strong but
it was so impactful that when I had my
first the first time I got pulled out of
the shoe to meet with the warden he
basically looked at me like I was some
some sort of a ghost or spirit for us or
something because you got understand I'm
sitting in a in a unit all day long I
don't have access to anything nothing
and there's this huge social media c
campaign being run in my name to support
me they're bringing my name up at Bop
hearings all my lawyers are constantly
calling in letters are constantly coming
in and and the and the warden looks at
me like I'm sort of a spirit he's like
how are you doing this who are you what
is going on and and of course I had no
idea what was going on I I thought he
was asking me about the phone call I
made and and so I was just like uh well
sir I just wanted to make a phone call
to let people know I was out of solitary
and thank him for the mail and
everything and I think that's when it
hit him that like wow this is really
organic like he's actually not pulling
any of these strings he has nothing to
do with this he doesn't even know what
I'm talking about uh and so he kind of I
think he realized it in that moment and
then um we we had a bit of a talk but uh
yeah the the the outpouring of support
my heart was just like about to burst
out of my chest like the like the Grinch
at the end of the movie on Mount Crumpet
but it really did affirm reaffirm my
faith in the American people most people
are good most people have good Hearts I
think some people are in situations
where they're just
scared and they're just lacking courage
and bravery to maybe do the right thing
or they're just confused they're not
even sure what they can do or how they
can do it but I I think that the the
good and people people's hearts is out
there it's just a matter of
somehow collecting it and directing it
into a Force for good to save this
country but I I I think it's inevitable
there's too much good there's too many
good people and and at the bottom of the
human soul is a desire to be free and
prosper that just cannot be put out it
just won't be I just want to clarify
your your comments though you know
obviously you have a lot to be grateful
for a lot of great people we're not
talking about Harrison though right F
[__] that guy right we love har everyone
except Harrison Smith we were telling
Harrison While you wereing we were like
you have the swords you need to go in
there like a Samurai and free him he did
nothing yeah all all that training with
the swords he did nothing for you okay
yeah well look I mean there were a lot
of marine veterans a lot of army
veterans that wrote me you know I've got
some friends that are some pretty epic
uh Navy Seals and stuff like that and
you know I may or may not have had some
movie style fantasy of 40 to 50 Marines
showing up fully armored at the jail
saying hey release my guy but uh that's
just a weird fantasy I may or may not
have had or maybe like some Shaw Shank
or Great Escape stuff any one of those
movies like that you know you put a
picture of a I didn't have enough time
to pull something like that 60 days I
mean come on he has to go with the Lean
on Me ending you can't have the [__]
sh you can't have the Sha shank it has
to be the lead for 20 years that's a
good point that's a really good point
that's a good point although I think you
know bunch of Marines showing up armed
at the prison probably would have made
the 60 days a little longer maybe a
little longer that might have ended in a
problem but you know wow Owen turned 60
days into 25 years to life I had nothing
to do with it I'm sitting in the shoe
officer I'm just sitting in my inch my
inch thick cck you didn't do anything
last time either that's the [__]
point that's the point you never did
anything to begin with you started a
chant if you did it at a goddamn college
football game you would have been fine
or you're just not allowed to do it in
front of this magical building or if you
were AOC you would have gotten away with
it too it's really all depends and
really you know it's a selective it's
it's it's selective imprisonment now
which honestly I don't think is very
sustainable how do you stay from being
bitter because man if I were you I would
be so [__] bitter I'm not you and I'm
bitter I'm not I'm not you and I'm
bitter for you you know what I mean you
guys you guys are you guys are you're
you're not bitter you're really not you
guys what you are is you're frustrated
at the corruption that is in our system
because a as you pointed out really it
remove Owen Shroyer as the person and
and just what is Owen Shroyer as the
concept I have proven Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt the two-tier justice
system I have proven Beyond a reasonable
doubt that there are two applications of
Justice you can do exactly what Owen
Shroyer did but if you come at it from
the leftwing perspective from the
anti-trump perspective from the
pro-abortion perspective all these left
causes if if you're a leftist and you do
what oyer did you are perfectly fine you
will never be arrested never be charged
never go to jail but if you're a enyer
and you do that lesser then you're going
to suffer the the full extent of the law
so so removing myself as just just a
human being as a concept the reason why
you're upset and bitter is because it
just proves Beyond a reasonable doubt
that you a conservative American the law
applies differently to you and if the
left does anything they want they will
never suffer the consequences but if you
engage in your lawful peaceful Free
Speech you're going to suffer the
consequences so I think that's that's
the political bitterness and frustration
that's where it comes through but as far
as why am I not bitter as a person I
love life too much life is way too
precious and and I just enjoy living way
too much to to to go about this life
bitter and really that's what they want
at a certain level the American left
wants you to be bitter and hate life and
drugged down by it just like they are
and that's why they love communism so
much and that's why they want to tell
you how to live your life so much
they're misery and they're looking for
company in their misery so we don't want
to join them in that misery and I refuse
to join them in that misery but without
a doubt without a doubt my case
politically does not go down in vain
because I've proven Beyond a reasonable
doubt that there are two applications of
Justice in this country and that
political imprisonment is a real thing
and now we have a situation where speech
imprisonment is a real thing so look my
struggle and everything they've done to
me is I hope that's not what you're
calling the
book my struggle yeah please don't call
it my struggle that's been taken that's
been taken don't do my struggle has it
yeah it has it has actually sorry could
couldn't help it hold on guys I'm going
to have to oh God let me I got to call
my editor give me give me a second yeah
we'll work with that's a working now
[__] so you're back on Twitter you happy
I get out of prison and I get out of
Twitter prison he's he's got two
twitters but here's the problem the new
Twitter he made has seems to have more
reach than his old Twitter because
everything on the new Twitter blows up
immediately well I think what's going on
is I think that there's still a lot of
Gremlins left in the system that musk
you know musk probably doesn't even have
the time at or even maybe the concern to
deal with it all so there's still a
bunch of Gremlins left around but the
way I'm approaching it now is that the O
tryer 1776 account which is new and
doesn't have all the old Gremlins
lurking around keeping it censored
that's going to be for all my political
stuff all my media stuff like with this
interview we shared it there right so
that's where you're going to see most of
the activity and then my old account at
all I do is own that's just going to be
a personal account I kind of want to
just keep that away from politics and
just do some personal stuff over there
maybe some videos or some posts every
once in a while but yeah I'm directing
the thrust of my media activity and my
politics at Owen Troyer 1776 because it
does much better and it's able to get
verified I can't even verify my old one
even though it was before it got
censored you by the way your your Rumble
show has been great I've checked a
couple of them out in the chat it's
really good it's fun you're taking calls
like it's I kind of like this like when
you're good on Rumble and you're in this
set so great it's a little more cash
it's like you know Owen tryer after dark
right like he's not cuz when you're
suit yeah you're all suited up on
Infowars and you're always like dressed
like an NFL analyst but then you do the
rumble show get I I oh don't even get me
started on that don't even get me
started on that Daddy makes me wear the
suit and
tie makes sense you know something else
that that I that I I did want to hit
because I know what we're coming towards
the end here but but something else I
want to hit is it has
been amazing to see a lot of what I
would I guess I would call Mainstream
conservative people that wouldn't touch
anybody on Infowars now having you on
having Alex on having all the just
people that oh six months ago wouldn't
even say your guys's name are now seeing
everything shift and like no let's have
these people on that has to be nice to
know that it it it's it was more people
are waking up to it and going like wait
a second these aren't boogey men this is
these are people that we we should be
able to talking to all these
people well let me give you uh kind of
both sides of this coin here and I'll
start with the more the more negative
side if you will um when I got out I
realized something and I've been making
the analogy that it's like a man who
smokes a pack a day for a decade then
doesn't smoke a cigarette for a decade
and then smokes his first cigarette he's
coughing up
Along being in there was a detox process
from the political world if you will the
media world and when I got out it was
like smoking that first cigarette I was
hacking up along and it it really made
made me realize what an animalistic
world the political media is I mean it's
like you know the rightwing wants to
point at the left wing for being
inhumane and not having a soul and a
conscious but let me get let me tell you
at a certain level the rightwing is the
exact same way I mean the desperation
for attention and for clout and the
chasing and the and the hamster wheel
and the rat race I got to tell you the
first 48 to 72 hours after getting out
and and dealing with that I was like I
mean honestly I was sickened by it I
mean part of me was like this is so
toxic and and
so just horrible and animalistic like I
was almost like I don't even want to
deal with this anymore um I was able to
power through it and uh I'm fine now and
I'm I'm pretty much 100% rearing and and
going now it's it's it's I'm you know I
guess you could say I'm toxified again
I'm smoking a pack I'm smoking a pack a
day again but I got to tell you those
first 72 hours those first cigarettes
man it was like this is gross like this
is nasty and it is it really is so I
think the monetization made it worse on
Twitter too it's made it far worse yeah
yeah so so the reason why I say that is
because if I'm looking at it from kind
of the negative standpoint I'm thinking
oh well these are people who are just
clout chasing these are people who are
just trying to use uh us now that we've
been completely validated and Vindicated
and going viral and everything um to to
get a step up now I'm not saying I
totally believe that I'm just pointing
out that other side of the coin but I
think most likely what's going on is
that if there were doubters or haters or
if there were people that felt you
couldn't have Alex Jones on the show or
Owen Troy on the show or others on the
show because they were afraid to getting
of getting censored or demonetized I
think that maybe that's kind of waned
and I think that maybe that fear has
kind of gone away or or maybe now these
topics of conversation they're more
willing to discuss so uh I I would say
that's the positive side of that coin I
hope that that's fully the case and and
not the lad that I talked about but I I
hope so because it signifies hopefully
the pendulum starting to swing back the
other way which is you know RP Steve c
yeah but but but it has it has like it
feels like the the the momentum is you
know and I think partly to do with
Twitter partly to do with with Tucker
and you know and and of course you know
what's been happening to you and what
happened to Alex I think people are
starting to going to realize this is not
sustainable we we can't turn into a
commy [__] hole this not going to happen
and people have been pushing back
because I think I do believe what you
said that people inherently Want to Be
Free whether they know it or not I think
it's it's part of our lizard brain you
know where we want to be free we don't
want to be locked down the lizard you
ever tried to catch a lizard it doesn't
want to be caught no that's a good point
it does not want to be caught I mean
look at Hillary Clinton's still free but
uh the
[Laughter]
but but uh no but it's it's it it has
been nice to see that I do understand
that look better that than than than
everybody it just I agree with the
disgusting part I agree with it being
dirty you see it all the time if you're
on Twitter for 10 minutes like you have
to like I have to get myself off of
Twitter because I'll [__] lose my
mind for a while because it's it's just
everybody vying for Content you know
stealing other people's stuff trying to
be the first person to this and that and
I want to say this here's a humble brag
mercan and I were down with the INF War
homies before it was safe and cool we
were riding with the old school we
didn't care we were never afraid we were
never afraid I just want to put that out
there I want to put that out there we
were never scared and also because we
know we're smaller than the rest of also
why we've nevery because we're nobody's
so it's fine yeah but yeah whatever but
whatever but by the way man thank you so
much for being on dude this we really
appreciate I did like a billion
interviews and I didn't want to bug you
to ask but I appreciate it yeah dude
seriously thanks for coming in and
always being a bro you man yeah you
you're a good dude by 5,000 watching now
hit the like button and go go watch go
subscribe to Owen's Rumble show it's
very good it's uh rumble.com uh it's
Owen yeah you got actually that pretty s
wait a second wait hold on SEC were we
just doing a show yeah this was a show I
thought we were just catching up we were
just this is how this this is this is
our show there's not a big format we
don't go to break break we're not
professionals I'm going to break the
fourth wall and something reason that I
like Owen cuz he does some the same
thing we do when we when we do Infowars
when we're on break he'll always try to
say two or three things to break us
right before we go back live and I'm
like oh God damn it he go like we're
coming back hey hey blah blah blah blah
blah I'm like hey guys welcome back to
like God damn it yeah we know we we have
the old uh op OPI and Anthony format
where guests come on in and go oh wait
were we actually
here dude seriously man thank you so
much and and honestly this is great to
see I mean I I think that the momentum
you have right now is is fantastic and
it's only going to grow and you've been
you've been killing it on we call it X
now whatever Twitter you know what I
mean and we're going back to Texas soon
and we owe you a steak and a totally not
alcoholic we owe you a steak and an ODS
yeah you go and an OD a steak and an
odul or high and zero whatever you want
on us man I owe you I owe you a steak
and a Yingling poured into an odul don't
worry I've been on probation before
brother I'll get you through this I can
get clean
piss wait a second you know the guy I
don't even want to say
it let's just say when you pee in the
cup you're not alone
okay you got you got an audience okay me
neither but that's what I do it at
public bathrooms I'm so glad you guys
are coming to Texas I look forward to
that yeah we we we'll definitely hang my
head out there man of course dude but
dude thank you thank you so much for
being on man and and go enjoy a merry
Christmas you know enjoy your Christmas
and stuff seriously wait a second that
reminds me before we go I even brought
this hat oh he has a Christmas hat look
at that I love it what's the that's very
is that like a cheetah print oh yeah oh
that's very like Mafia That's like a
mafia Guido Christmas that I found a
there was a cheetah roaming around Texas
I don't know how it got in here or maybe
I was at a zoo or something I don't know
but I chased it down with my bare hands
and I said turn this into a hat and uh
this is what I got that's why the San
Antonio Zoo was saying they were missing
a cheetah I think we figured out why oh
maybe it was a zoo I I don't you know I
just I just saw a cheetah and wanted a
hat oh and man thank you so much dude
and obvious obviously you you're not not
at this now you're like you know you're
like Tucker level but you're always
welcome on the show you need to plug
anything obviously you know that so well
I love you guys peace and love brothers
can't wait good to see you out hey dude
yeah Merry Christmas yeah Merry
Christmas dude see you later mermas
Merry Christmas one and all there goes
Owen take it easy go check out his
Rumble show it's awesome yeah I've been
posting the link in the chat the whole
time so uh that was that was that was
fun man Owen's Owen's the best yeah he's
and you know something that people don't
really real and and I want to I want to
make very clear like the Owen you see is
the Owen you get cuz you a lot of times
you see people on like on air and stuff
and then you hang out with them like
that is a not the same that's Owen is
Owen you know if anything Owen's even
more fun yeah if anything he's even more
crazy but in a good way not in illegal
way probation I will say even even
Harrison like off the air is a little
crazier than he is on the air like most
like he he buttons it up a little bit
Harrison's fun it's fun he's he's Bas as
[__] fun he super based but yeah
Owen's definitely same on the off the
air and I would say Alex is Alex Jones
is the same on and off the air too a
little less yelling just a yeah a little
little a little yes but he's the still
the same energy the energy is there for
sure pacing around smoking a cette way
shout out to because I know a bunch of
infow War people's worth listening shout
out to everyone in infow Wars everyone
we've met in infow Wars has been been
[__] awesome even the security guard
who who lets me be annoying and smoke
every [__] 15 minutes mer kept going
out there smoking and they're like come
on man [__]
Christ but shout out to everyone INF for
Wars and you know it's I I really do
think that hopefully they get this this
Alexa settle and they bounce back big
because they got all the momentum going
right now
m